congratulations i know you got married
this year thank you
and um i have to say you have a series
of portraits from your wedding
that are i think the best wedding
portrait series i've ever seen
oh i i appreciate it was a pretty
special moment
here's it starts off and everything's
just lovely
right that's a great wedding shot then i
love
this you sense trouble
something's coming right it's coming
your way but we don't know what it is
yet
and that's the drama right right
bang wait starts to break
they're shrieking then it intensifies
and kind of looks like maybe you two
will be lost at sea forever
for sure right and then i love
the aftermath soaking wet but happy
what are you
that's a great wedding are you going to
get it all framed together that's
fantastic
yeah we got to get them printed out and
just put them you know in some sort of
succession in a frame i think it would
be hilarious i just love that
the picture where i first see the wave
yeah you think i was about to be
murdered
yes the way that i'm looking so scared
in that way which should have told my
wife
that i am not the person that's going to
be able to protect her
in our marriage yeah well she knows that
now she knows that now
it would have been great if you panicked
and pushed her in front of the wave
that you should have done yes i've
always thought that's what a spouse is
for
um
we have a clip here from the movie
yesterday that you're in anything we
need to know about this
clip i know the premises of the film is
obviously
parents that give their kids permission
pretty much to have
anything they want they get to call the
shots for 24 hours
with and then comedy ensues comedy
ensues yeah
this scene is with jennifer garner and
you know she
is awesome it was it was just cool to
get to do this
with her and uh i'm the cat i'm the
person that she kind of
tells that she's having this really bad
moment
as part of this day and i offer up uh
some pretty solid advice in my opinion
i'm sure you do let's take a look at
this clip from yesterday are you okay
yeah i i just got into a fight with my
husband
uh and you want me to beat him up no no
nothing like that
give him a wedgie no no it's just that
today was the first day in like a year
where i felt like we were really
in it together yeah and then he just had
to go and be a wuss
sounds like karen she's mad because i
took our life savings and bought a fleet
of ambulances and i barely know how to
drive this one
but you can't force people to change you
got to do what works for you and he can
either join the party or it's his loss
you know
that's so true not good advice really
i love when people who clearly have make
terrible decisions give advice that's my
it's my favorite part of life i offered
to beat up her husband
i you know whatever well she should have
just said yeah do that
yeah yesterday and give b give him a
wedgie then beat him up
um well yesterday will be available to
stream on netflix on friday
keenan returns to nbc march 16th man
this is insane
barb and star is available on demand new
episodes of the netflix after party will
be announced on netflix is a joke
and fortunes podcast sincerely fortune
is available wherever
you get your podcast enough already
fortune it's
it's insane conan if you need me to be a
part of your band
uh i've got some extra time i got no
bands so yes
yes yeah you can grab that guitar